electricity doesn't go off as often
anymore
in the last few weeks power Cuts in
Zimbabwe have lasted just a few hours
not like before when some areas will go
without electricity for most of the day
but zimbabweans don't know how long this
latest Improvement in power supply will
go on for
so I urge Farmers to maybe have a backup
of electricity like generator or solar
powered engine so that if electricity is
gone they're able to it'll get there
with
Indian not letting it
go dry because wheat needs water and
water needs electricity to indicate our
fields
another challenge of doing business here
is a high price of goods and basic
Commodities government leaders insist
the economy is improving but some
economists say it's not growing fast
enough around 40 of zimbabweans are
living in extreme poverty and of course
there's not been associated with the
creation of a lot of employment
opportunities where every year we have
almost 300 000 School leavers and
graduates that are leaving our schools
and our colleges and the economy can't
absorb them into a full and productive
employment opportunities president
Administration says economic sanctions
imposed by some countries in the west
more than 20 years ago on reports of
Human Rights abuses are to blame as well
as economic sabotage critics of the
government the inconsistent policies
corruption and mismanagement are some of
the reasons why the economy is
struggling
there was a time when trained wagons
would roll through here picking up and
dropping of goods from the different
companies in the area that hasn't
happened in years now there is just
silence and what's left of the structure
is falling apart all the presidential
candidates say they will create jobs and
economic opportunities if elected the
municipalities no Reviving an economy
that's been relatively dormant for more
than two decades will not be easy
foreign